I want to start today with genuinely just
very good news, you might remember that last
week on Monday, we learned that Pfizer reported
that their vaccine in their data is shown
to be 90 percent effective at preventing coronavirus
infections.
It was not yet peer reviewed this morning,
just hours ago.
Moderna, based here in Boston, says that its
vaccine is ninety four point five percent
effective in preventing covid-19.
This is interim data from a late stage clinical
trial data on which they will be seeking immediate
emergency use, authorization to start vaccinating
people.
And we are very quickly pointed in the direction,
of course, pending those approvals of the
U.S. having two vaccines authorized for emergency
use by December with as many as 40 to 60 million
doses available and being distributed by the
end of this year.
Medicine, as interim analysis was based on
ninety five infections among participants
who received either the placebo or a vaccine.
Of those 95 people who got the virus, only
five had received the vaccine.
The other 90 had received a placebo.
In other words, not the vaccine.
This was with the two doses 28 days apart,
as is expected to be the sort of eventual
protocol for this vaccine.
Also very important, the data from modern
US thirty thousand participant trial showed
that the people who got the vaccine and got
coronavirus, in other words, that roughly
five percent who, despite having the vaccine
were not completely protected, seemed to have
significantly less serious cases of coronavirus.
So that's a question that's still in the air
about the Fizer vaccine.
One of the other major differences between
the Moderna and the Fizer vaccine is that
unlike the Fizer vaccine, the Moderna vaccine
requires only standard refrigeration.
One of the issues with the Fizer vaccine was
that it requires refrigeration well below
the temperatures that, like a typical flu
vaccine, might require.
And so from an infrastructure standpoint,
the Moderna vaccine also having huge, huge
promise just as far as the ease of distribution.
And it simplifies infrastructure requirements
dramatically.
The Fizer vaccine has to be shipped and stored
at minus 70 C 70 Celsius, and that's certainly
a challenge.
So you couldn't ask for better news?
Of course, we need to go through the process,
peer reviewing the data, getting that emergency
use authorization.
If you don't trust the FDA, these are vaccines.
We now have two vaccines that are going to
be presumably seeking approval in other countries
as well.
So if you trust a different country's health
agency, as you would not be crazy to do during
a time when the FDA and CDC have been so politicized
by the Trump administration, you will have
presumably approvals from other countries
as well, at least before the vaccine is widely
available to people of all ages.
And I think it makes sense to mention it does
not seem like these companies and from what
I've seen, the Moderna CEO to me has always
seemed like a guy on the up and up the development
in Germany with biotech and this Turkish immigrant.
Couple of the what is now being called the
Pfizer vaccine.
So far, the point I'm trying to make is I've
not seen evidence that either of these individuals
are running organizations that would try to
get approval for their vaccine before it was
ready.
Trump wanted them to do it as quickly as possible.
Trump said 100 million doses in October.
And I would have been worried if that had
happened because it seemed like it would have
been too soon.
December, based on the data we now have, seems
logical.
And that's sort of where my head is right
now.
Now, I want to mention one other thing.
You start doing the math, OK?
If we have two vaccines, 60 million doses
in December, you need two doses.
So that would be like for 30 million people,
that's only 10 percent, nine percent of the
country.
And then maybe you get another total for thirty
five million people in January if you start
doing math.
And it seems like it's going to be a long
time before any of us will be able to get
a vaccine.
The latest surveys indicate that 40 percent
of the country doesn't have any plan to get
this vaccine.
Now, that represents potential herd immunity
issues.
But separately, remember, if 40 percent of
the country doesn't want the vaccine, 400
million doses would be enough for everybody
who wants the.
Scene to get both doses that they need 28
days apart, so the point is it's bad that
40 percent of the country doesn't want the
vaccine from a herd immunity standpoint.
You and I, if you are in sort of my demographic
sort of position, age and health range, you
and I may be able to get a vaccine far sooner
as a result of having hopefully two approved
vaccines and 40 percent of the country not
wanting it.
It does raise longer term questions, though.
About 40 percent of the country not wanting
the vaccine.
We have a possible game changer here.
Let's not get ahead of ourselves.
We've seen Foushee on vaccine timeline be
more optimistic lately than we've ever seen
him.
And if things go the way they are pointing,
we could have a second half of twenty twenty
one.
That looks dramatically better than 20/20.
I don't want to make any more hyperbolic claim
than that.
I'm not even thinking of things like completely
back to normal.
But in the meantime, masks, distancing, not
having huge indoor Thanksgivings.
All of those things have to continue because
we're back up to fifteen hundred people a
day dying.